Comcast of course we will send these 44
seconds of unnecessary logos even though
they are likely the only thing that will
make sense for the next two hours does
your son usually say uncle Jonas is here
when he's not otherwise your incredulity
is pure dickish nonsense on what day did
the Norwegian Parliament hold his first
election since the war August 12th 1945
homeschooling it normally sucks when you
buy a house like this you always make
sure the master bedroom has an inside
peeping window uncle Jonas apparently
has a sixth sense since zero sound was
made and he would therefore have no
reason to assume the perv kid was spying
on them so this piece of human refuse
comes over runs through the Roberts
rules of abusing people and you're
yelling at him to stay I have a better
response and it involved four middle
fingers Wow six if you count the Snowman
I'm getting the distinct feeling the
Norwegian Tourism Board was not
consulted during this film well he gives
you an early warning of his intentions
with the sound of the main character
snoring over the opening credits as no
one in Norway heard of gloves first the
kid made a snowman without them and now
our protagonist slept outside without
them they have been invented here right
the Snowman you're being too modest this
is clearly the greatest snowman and it's
the true story of PT Barnum's serial
killer phase how do you pick up a title
jeez Wow dark brooding alcoholic
antihero wakes up on a public bench with
a hangover cliche also replace the
sunniness of LA with the snow eNOS of
Oslo and a Smith with a Fassbender but
damn this opening feels very Hancock iam
also also assuming Harry spent most of
the night here and I see no evidence of
a heater he should be if not dead
severely frostbitten I swear I'm gonna
catch my death in pneumonia just by
watching this movie as well as at least
three biddies I'm guessing if there is
one thing these statues make clear it's
that the White Witch has taken up
residency in Norway and I'm guessing
Aslan ain't coming come to Oslo where
you and your family can spend a nice day
in the park and have a picnic right by
the statue depicting the great circle
jerk of 1864 and when we say based just
so we're clear we mean it has a couple
of the same character names but we
change pretty much everything else and
left out anything that would in any way
make this a coherent story line right
there are so many reactions like this in
the movie - absolutely nothing it's as
if every character woke up this morning
and we're told they were going to be in
a thriller today this guy keeps his gun
next to
classic Sex Pistols album in this
household Harry believes in gun storage
that is both unsafe and poetic where
exactly did this guy come from Harry had
to pass the kitchen to get to the point
he's at currently and yes hazmat man is
not in the previous shot but in the time
it takes Harry to walk to get the gun
turn around
surely he would have noticed Harry the
very least Wow yep that's right the
protagonists name is Harry frickin hole
Harry hole was the author just browsing
his 1970s porn collection when it came
to him how am I supposed to take it here
this seriously
also in Norway Harry's last name would
be pronounced as Holy but since
Americans are stupid movie decides to
make Harry's name sound more fitting for
porn mind you Harry holy is a dumbest
name as well does this guy not see Harry
with a gun in his hand or is this how
people greet each other in Norway just
like in real life when you see someone
you know you stare at them as the camera
cuts back and forth for a full 10
seconds just so everything stays
perfectly ominous the EBI sync will
automatically upload all the new data to
the central police server here every 12
hours in a movie that lacks anything
resembling a linear or cohesive
storyline let's be sure to make a point
to explain what version of software the
police are using for their tablets also
the Ewa sink what is this nonsense
why would it need 12 hours to sink there
are modern cells in this movie right why
would these giant iPad wannabes with
such a horrible refresh rate even be
used by a modern police force I'd like
to put $100 down on later force plot
point thanks nave of absence has to be
formally requested in writing between
this and the ever sink seminar we just
sat through this movie is starting to
feel more like an admin instructional
video on the inner workings of the Oslo
Police Department and that might have
put a more interesting film Norwegian
serial-killer would be great at writing
cinema since you scared my clients away
I'm guessing Raquel's infidelity least
art selling strategy didn't help matters
not to belabor the dangers of sleeping
outside when it's below freezing but
here he's literally sleeping in the snow
this arm should have been amputated long
ago who hit me with a snowball who cares
I got the promotion over Silvie and more
than once to marry me so I can forget
about a mysterious snowball faster than
takes to melt one inhale we're Sylvie's
going goddammit
assuming the killer is the one who hit
this woman with a snowball how enough
did he get back in his car without her
seeing him am I going to create a ton of
sins from this phone exchange yes I am
first off this girl picks up her phone
because it beeped but why did the phone
beep she was the last person to write
anything in this exchange that series of
face screaming in fear emojis are on her
side of the conversation also
the I miss you text that she's about to
send is already on the phone in the shop
but disappears in the next one and she
goes to write it furthermore the I miss
you text his back on the screen before
she even sends it movie might promote
brutal serial killings but it does not
abide texting and driving for the record
I'm not sure stopping in the middle of
the road to text is that much safer even
if it is just an excuse to let the
killer pass which will have zero impact
on future events anyway if you want to
silently roll credits after this
exchange I would not have a problem with
that
this girl's mom is terrible at taking
pictures of snowmen why selfie this your
cogging the snowman's frame woman this
long lingering look at her husband tries
to make it seem like he might be the
killer but it's so ridiculously obvious
he isn't he might as well be played by
Tom Hanks it's a good thing no one ever
uses blinds or curtains in this film
because our poor killer wouldn't be able
to spy on them properly and know when
best to strike I'm Katrina Brett re-home
how dare you sir oh wait are you saying
that's your name this is a common thing
in Norway the inside window you guys
have built up a level of trust in which
I am totally jealous and going to give
us in four because I don't trust what
I'm seeing this movie and it's going
back and forth the little girl's mom
probably got killed and it's probably
the most interesting part of the movie
so far but instead we're going back to
Sleepy Michael Fassbender and his
never-ending melancholy people playing
ping pong is an app symbol of this
movies editing can't believe Velma
Schoonmaker did this thing so this
machine is called a vsync previously on
the sink I saw Josephine in the garden
in her pajamas and I thought what's she
doing out in this coat considering the
clothing or lack thereof already seen
this film like pajamas in the freezing
snow make as much sense as anything else
and she said she couldn't find her
mother I feel like half this movie was
shot outside of windows you can't hear
most of the dialogue in these shots
although the subtitles are handy I
suppose but what about when you're at
the theater oh good article about
important character later in the film is
conveniently found in Katrina's glove
box how um convenient okay cool
now they're in Bergen nine years earlier
oh Christ also have we gone back to a
time when people act like normal human
beings and don't just stare at each
other ominously before making every
action seemed to deliberate and creepy
nope
guess not I checked her credit card
bills
she's been to see a pregnancy dumb job
who says pregnancy doctor was he located
next door to the teeth doctor or the
booboo treating doctor movie makes it
seem as if Harry is having a memory of
an event that took place nine years ago
oh that he has no knowledge of this is
when Harry realizes maybe I should have
paid a little more attention to that
letter where someone said they were
going to kill someone else
yeah the drawing doesn't look anything
like this also glad I kept this strange
senseless snowman letter right nearby
for this very moment
even though it really meant nothing to
me you want a coffee or something we are
thirty minutes into this frosty the
snooze fest and we still basically know
nothing about anything
never has a movie taken so long to tell
you so Lou here's an extra 10 cents for
the sheer boredom this guy just leaves
his orange juice out all day if he
doesn't get frostbite from sleeping
outside he's going to get eco live from
the spoiled OJ in White Walkers hey
guess what a drunken raft oh somehow new
to walk up to spin sin right as the
other officers we're talking about him
also were the other officers not aware
that either raft or Svendsen could have
a walkie-talkie tuned to the channel
they are all clearly on cold case cold
case that's good stuff right there not
sure who wrote this SNL skit but Bravo I
think it's the falling snow that's
that's the killer off
I'll get this movie this it's the first
film I know of where the motive is snow
porn damn it if this movie cuts away
from what is interesting one more time I
will become the snow man myself or Val
Kilmer whichever is scarier why the
is this kid pulling off his master in
the middle of a hockey game hi Harry
good to see you sorry I'm late honey I
was busy killing women and building
snowmen that have to do with anything
this kid shoots the puck it pleases
Michael Fassbender for some reason and
game is over the hockey game on the roof
in clerkes was better than this and some
asshole in the middle of that game
launched the ball they were using down
the street all she cares about is you
that's why she dumped me such a bad
insurance but she still lets me take you
out by myself all the time
people pay money to see this also this
is a perfectly plausible response to
having to sit through half of this movie
Harry there's another missing woman in
gala this time okay so here he gets a
call from Catrin about a new missing
woman and at about the 40 minute mark
you'd think that would finally mean this
movie's gonna get into the mystery and
stop worrying about Harry's hockey game
in concert attendance instead the movie
takes us to his ex-girlfriend's place so
he can drop off Oleg and then Harry says
this take the O go in the morning so
mean we have to go back to Harry's house
with a pill bottle in his hand rather
than a simple fast forwarding to the
morning get on with it already moving
you a very little time left a snowman
also why was it so important for Catrin
to come get Harry and interrupt his semi
father-son outing if they were just
gonna go check on the missing woman in
the morning thus Fassbender have no
shame who reported on missing her
husband last night sure I had this
conversation last night when you can
simply do it in the morning while the
movie wastes even more time inspector
hole I hardly even known never mind I'm
Anna Peterson so he was my sister my
twins and despite the fact that I'm at
the house where my sister was just
murdered I somehow don't know she's been
murdered
oh by the way this murder and the twin
connection and the fact that I'm being
played by a Chloe Sevigny is totally
immaterial to the rest of the movie also
how is aunt even here clearly the line
about Sylvia's husband going to pick up
the sister was bull since after Harry
and Catrin leave Sylvia calls her
husband and tells him to stop calling
her and showing up so how did they I
just happen to show up and how could
they have been gone longer than an hour
and why is it nighttime so our killer
was able to find this place shimmy down
make a snowman put a human head on it
and get out in just a few minutes but
the experts are still trying to repel
down there I guess you can limit your
search to snow ninjas then I guess after
this we're gonna have to call her Chloe
Sevigny she wasn't sure who the father
was she got rid of the baby a few weeks
ago we get it the killer is killing
women whom he feels are immoral we've
gotten that since the opening suicide by
ice car but you've yet to do anything to
actually drop clues or hints or even red
herrings about who this might be or why
we would care you forgot to put in any
mystery into your murder mystery so far
so here's another 15 sins to think about
what you don't so after finding her head
the only natural place to go under that
is a black-tie ice-skating party it's
definitely time to talk to JK Simmons
now because after all we've seen his
picture twice in this movie once in this
newspaper and another time in this
magazine from the nine years ago a Val
Kilmer part of the story have Catrin and
Harry even talked about this guy yet
wait isn't that the same song as was
playing in the most recent victims home
I'm barely paying attention anymore and
I recognize that so how does he not
question this guy and why does none of
this even matter does this guy just live
in the neighborhood what are the chances
of him being here is Mateus walks past
him in the suit also this guy sees
someone in a hazmat suit and thinks that
guy must be impersonating me I better
say something also also mold man and the
snowman I see a three-picture franchise
and a Netflix series her head washed
ashore yeah Aaron don't wait arendelle
like from frozen
I knew Olaf had a dark side but yikes
Magnus kept me the list what list the
list of doctors at the Gillian oh yes of
course that's what he meant by the list
it's so obvious when you think about it
how did you know Sophie Utterson was
pregnant eat of it and we have our first
suspect granted most murder mysteries
provide a couple of those in the first
30 minutes or so but not the Snowman
nope too much importance tearing into
blizzards to think about suspects until
Matt paint it don't nail this is
important because all right nothing
means anything in this godforsaken
wasteland of a movie despite not being
the murderer doctor vet listen has a
serial killer collage on his wall they
really can't just say Olympics and even
if they can't couldn't come up with
something better than Winter Sports
World Cup attending a three-day
conference on bioidentical hormone
restoration I thought you were a plastic
surgeon Wow no cosmetics surgery needs
to move with the times too
I'm working on this process where I can
give a woman the body of a snowman also
seriously does Harry not find it
remotely odd that mattias just happens
to be on this train this time I look at
this picture now staring at huh now how
could you not see that before it's in
the middle of the goddamn picture you're
not even pretending to look straight
Matthias is not a police officer how
would he have any clue they would still
be tracking the phone or even if they
were how quickly they could get to the
location
why is everything in this world so
suspicious it's a ringing foam Dara I'm
not gonna lie the last 20 minutes of
this movie has been so nonsensical and
boring I'm not even sure where to start
Keller blew his head off except he
didn't it was the snowman guy but then
Magneto's detective friend who was
apparently old Kilmer guy's daughter
followed a phone to another house with a
doctor blew their head off and now the
bossy guy from whiplash is surprised and
I'm not sure any of it actually means
anything or if I've just lost all
feeling in my extremities including my
brain he's found two bodies in the house
and Berta Becca's phone it was a suicide
case closed
detective boss sees circumstantial
evidence and declares the big case not
to be such a big case after all and
probably can't be convinced otherwise
because the lead detective is a drunk
who lost all this credibility cliche
also being a serial killer and Norway
must be so boring the police don't even
try to investigate these crimes
no wonder Matthias sends cute notes to
the cops can I keep this
no can I keep this yes right after all
you made a real convincing argument just
a movie I mean why why did he call you
cloudberry that's a good question you
seem like a guy who would be more
partial to calling someone huckleberry
the most interesting character trait in
this entire film might be how opposed
hereas Tibet's well guys we're about 25
minutes away from the end of this movie
and we have absolutely no leads into who
the killer is
but we do have time for Raquel and Harry
nah skeptically dry-humping you've seen
now that phone's definitely exist in
this universe
why on earth would this giant ever sink
nonsense be a better way to capture
offending video No
hello Catrin clearly noticed that
someone turned off all the lights in the
room while she was in the bathroom and
her decision instead of checking on who
did that was to just get in the bed and
watch some TV and then she act surprised
when she realized that someone else is
in the room how exactly did Matthias get
up to this room this quickly after
getting off the phone with Raquel how
did he even get in the room 15 has been
awarded to Oslo so glad they wrapped up
the world-cup storyline that had
absolutely zero bearing on any part of
the movie doesn't even give the killer
motive if say it was Stoke wouldn't it
have been easier and less messy to just
bring the tablet over to katrin's body
to get in as opposed to chopping her
finger off also how does Matthias know
about this tablet or that it's
fingerprint encode doesn't this movie
make a ton more sense if a police
officer is doing the crime it's not like
if it wasn't matthias than we would work
at least as much as it works in its
current form how do you make an imprint
of a snowman this pristine on the top of
without disturbing the other snow around
it did this rent a crane so
he could drop a trash can lid in a
bowling ball on the roof to make this
thing you got to admire the dedication
and stealth of this asshole
he killed Catrin in a hotel where
there's a huge celebration going on
managed to somehow get her body out of
that hotel without anyone seeing it
drove her here positioned her just so
made a snowman imprint on the top of the
car so that Harry would see it and
manage to do that without one witness
okay fine another debt which would be
fine if you had left any breadcrumbs to
follow or clues to parse but this whole
affair just feels like someone scratched
a bunch of names on a notepad and is
waiting until the two hours is up to
circle a person who did it
amateur jump-scare from a child as a
mature and childish darling ganache
inside I'm coming in a minute okay did
she hear that through the glass the hood
of her jacket the cap and her hair it
was never about you and there it is it's
the ex-girlfriends new boyfriend except
there has been literally nothing in this
movie that would lead us to believe
that's even a possibility up until this
point but TSS digital photo frame is
conveniently on the picture of Catrin
outside Raquel's apartment when Harry
looks at it furthermore since Harry
already knows Matthias is the killer
with his victim dossier spread out all
over the table this ridiculous picture
being here is even more ridiculous
Magnus track Raquel's phone why wouldn't
he just turn Raquel's phone off I didn't
think you'd find me
perhaps the pills help doctor Oh bad and
leaving Raquel's cell phone on so the
police could track you why did you
abandon them why is Matthias giving
Harry a chance to save Raquel and Olli
he didn't think Harry would find him so
it looks like he planned on killing them
if Harry didn't show up but now that he
is suddenly he needs to teach a lesson
also while we're at it let's talk about
the snowman's plan nine years ago he
killed a woman because she was going to
have an abortion for a child that was
not her husband's apparently this was
the only woman he ever ran across in his
entire history that sparked his snowman
rage
he killed Val Kilmer when he got too
close then he stopped killing altogether
until nine years later when he started
killing again for reasons unknown like
why did he kill Britta bishop she loved
her child and never once tried to
abandon her which is the ultimate reason
this movie is giving for the murders
trying to kill Raquel makes no sense for
the same reasons killing first Chloe
Sevigny follows the pattern because she
was going to have an abortion even
though the introduction of second Chloe
Sevigny made no sense I guess what I'm
saying here is that the most ridiculous
scene in the movie is the only thing
that actually makes sense man
okay wait a second what just happened
here there's no way to tell in a regular
speed so let's break it down Fassbender
somehow communicates to the kid to kick
his chair back when the guy looks that
way this somehow gives him the ability
to reach out and what get a finger in
there how does this help I think could
easily chop off a head and I doubt an
extra finger makes a difference what a
dumbass
come on this guy's native Norwegian what
a rookie mistake I'm from Tennessee and
I wouldn't piss up also they use ice
mocking up also why was Mattias even
walking closer to Harry he could have
shot him easily from where he was
standing pathologist can't determine
what kind of weapon was used and he's
never seen anything like I'll take it
obvious sequel is obviously not gonna be
made also based on the last hour and 54
minutes I just suffered through I'm
willing to bet that I'll take it is what
Fassbender says after every script he
reads
[Music]
[Applause]
I don't like you because you're
dangerous that's right
nice man I am dangerous which is why the
biggest challenge of IBS is educating
the public afflicts over 2 million
people yet most of us have never heard
of it and it strikes without regard age
gender or race my family owned all of
these buildings I remember when this was
all farmland as far as the eye could see
oh man Peabody owned all of this you had
this crazy idea about breeding pine
trees what am I gonna say I killed the
president of Paraguay with a fork how
have you been watch me I'll do the
fingering as he grumpy often join do you
like movies about gladiators maybe this
will bring your balls back my testicles
summer
hello mr. donkey that's not the wallet
inspector
[Music]